من زملائه غوارديولا يوصلوا تحطيم الارقام
القياسيه ومورينيو يزرع جهاز التجسس بين
الحكام هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
احتاج للعب احدى وثلاثين مباراه فقط في
الدوري الانجليزي ليحطم رقم
ويصبح اكثر لاعب يسجل في موسم واحد
بالمسابقه هالاند ساهم في فوز فريقه امام
ويستام بتسجيله الهدف الثاني رافع رصيده
الى 35 هدفا ويملك فرصه كبيره للتحطي حاجز
الاربعين هدفا قبل انتهاء المنافسه
لم يكن هالاند الوحيد الذي خرج برقم
القياسي من مباراه فريقه بعدما اصبح بيب
غوارديولا اسرع مدرب يسجل فريقه الف هدف
في الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز متخطيا ارسم
غوارديولا وصل الى هذا الرقم في 440
مباريات فقط اي اقل ب150 مباراه من ناظره
بنجر المدرب الاسطوري لنادي ارسنال
كثف نادي باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي
الاجراءات الامنيه حول مقر نادي وايضا
امام منازل نيمار ميسي و بسبب الجماهير
الغاضبه من اداء الفريق محليا خاصه بعد
الخساره امام بثلاثيه وكانت الجماهير قد
ذهبت ضد نجوم الفريق في المدرجات بعد
الاقصاء من دوري الابطال لكن تراجع نتائج
الفريق محليا زاد مساحه الجماهير التي
حاصرت منازل اللاعبين وطلبتهم بالرحيل
جزي مورينيو المثير للجدل والمعروف بصدمه
مع الحكام وضع جهاز التجسس على الخط
الجانبي للملعب خلال مباراه فريقه روما
امام مونزا في الدوري الايطالي والهدف منه
هو التجسس على حديثه حكم اللقاء مورينيو
بررت تصرفه بانه اراد حمايه نفسه من
الحكام وقراراتهم التعسفيه ضد فريقه كما
هاجم حكم المباراه الاخيره لفريقه ووصفه
بانه اسوا حكم شاهده في حياته